welcome to this video fritz car Fritz
car again young I don't know the last
game I don't remember what the last game
was did we have a king's indian there as
well I don't know ok I'll play the our
buck and we get an e5 kind of approach
95 here
isn't beef is before I movie I mean I'm
kind of irritated at the moment but
everything 95 isn't isn't it sits but
i'm a bit mystified yet I always thought
95 is is simply not playable if it was
people would probably play it okay so
interesting you have it where's the
night going if I go rook c1 III or what
is the move okay let's do this first and
then think about it III maybe just III
yeah otherwise I will just take it
afford it take away the foursquare okay
so on look-see to you're going to play
Knight be one yeah okay and I look d1
what are you doing then III or
III is hanging somewhat yeah but
and whatever we add position is also
this d6 issue is still in the position
Bishop F 393 shot what a mess up I would
like to get this poem but i don't think
i can really sacrifice the exchange okay
well what he did is he played all this
very quickly I mean half super committal
stuff again was played with instant
moose just as we know it hmm ok so maybe
develop some stuff are now walking seven
or what no
94 c eight gym i guess i have to do
something like that
what a viet game takes d6c for maybe no
idea total mess
1387 bishop is 3d7 I really don't know
what's going on here so Bishop c4 or
whoopsie form yeah Bishop c4 this this
is Bishop takes c3 yep chinks chinks not
working what a mess nice this definitely
okay my my pawn is not not going
anywhere we can just take only 3 yeah
didn't do that don't know exactly why
not but I mean I'm not saying that his
moves bad but he could have played that
I can take take that and tear Bishop e3
and I don't have I don't have now that
was stupid but it was really really not
again not good right he will take III
anyway can just take here and take only
3 and then c5 falls I completely lost
the weigh-in this complications time
morning now that's it's useless white
resign yeah it was very tricky I mean it
probably wasn't good for black but it
was very tricky definitely I don't know
isn't this I thought that you cannot
play 95 here I am i confusing things
here maybe I am I don't know however
this is it isn't that great i mean did
this move is kind of kind of crazy to
play yeah taking away the last square
for the night but it seems to work for
whatever reason this year I mean
computer says equal known but I made
some some some probably some mistakes I
mean certainly when I lost but this I
and one problem was he got very very
active so i have to do something else
here maybe like f3 but blackest yeah
Bishop f5 is coming it's probably just
probably just good for black here and I
computer is giving him a huge advantage
maybe I'm confusing lines am it looks
like that this is this is even this new
form oh it seems strong here Bishop age
six and then stuff III he's just very
very active and my my bishop 1c seven
assists rendered
I wonder if here what is forever take it
by the way maybe this is what i need to
do just give away an exchange I mean not
quite sure if you should try to win aid
immediately but this is this is
certainly no egg can take him that's
definitely good huh maybe but the whole
thing I mean he can do this and this
this renders the whole thing as
problematic so I just confused lines
here I guess before isn't a great move I
just have to play a free yeah I played
that well okay thanks for watching